- [Voiceover] Police say the shots
came from one or more vehicles.
- [Voiceover] Over 12 hundred shootings
in the city so far this year.
- [Voiceover] It's time
for someone to step up
and stop some of this violence.
- Englewood is historically one
of the worst neighborhoods
in the city of Chicago
and, also, in the entire
United States of America.
There have been children murdered
while sleeping in their beds
because bullets penetrated the walls
while they were sleeping.
Englewood is generally a
place where no one feels safe.
What brought me to the
corner of 75th and Stewart
was a young lady was murdered.
Her name was Lucille Barnes.
She was 34 and she was a mother
and she was just trying
to break up a fight
and she was killed in a drive-by.
I didn't know her, but I was outraged
and I felt like, at this point,
if mothers are being murdered,
something has to be done.
(dramatic music)
What size are they?
Some people thought that
it was too dangerous
to go and sit on a corner
in a place where someone
had just been murdered three days before.
We went out, we put on pink t-shirts
and we went and sat on the corner.
We got some hot dogs and we fed
people, we talked to people.
More importantly, we
gave out a lot of hugs.
So we got together, these
moms who had the time
and who had the passion for it
and I felt that, you know, being there
and being present and
having eyes on the street
and eyes on the children
that it would interrupt
and it would prevent
a lot of stuff that
could potentially happen.
There you go! Woo!
While you're doing that,
you're playing a game
with a kid that you may
never get to play with.
We want them to grow up together
so that when they're
older, they're not enemies
and they're not targets of one another,
they're not shooting
or killing each other.
Since we posted up on the
corner of 75th and Stewart,
there have been no
shootings on that block.
No shootings, no murders,
there hasn't even been
as much as a fistfight.
There's a sense of hope
that they didn't have before
all because we're mothers
and you don't want to underestimate
the power of the mother.
(dramatic music)